Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Und das alles in der Beta-Phase von Wikileaks. Das heißt, das Ding ist noch gar nicht so, wie sich die Macher das eigentlich vorstellen. Thomas, ist deine Frage übrigens damit beantwortet? Alles klar, dann machen wir mal Platz für die nächsten, wünsche dir noch einen schönen Tag.
Ja, euch noch eine schöne Sendung, macht's gut.
Auf dem Elf. Boah, was eine spannende Sendung. Chaosradio Nummer 149 auf Fritz, ihr seid mittendrin. Frank Rosengrat vom CCC ist da, Daniel Schmidt von Wikileaks ist auch hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden heute über Wikileaks. Die erste Stunde war schon extrem spannend und es kommt noch viel mehr. Gebt uns mal kurz eine Sekunde, um mal Luft zu schnappen. Wir sind gleich wieder bei euch. Das Ding geht irgendwann noch Ende des Jahres in die Liste der besten Songs dieses Sommers ein. Gebrünn, gebrünn, Paul Kalkbrenner. Ihr seid im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über Wikileaks. Daniel Schmidt von Wikileaks ist hier und der nächste am Telefon ist Erik. Hallo Erik, guten Abend.
Hallo und zwar meine Frage ist, hattet ihr schon mal Probleme mit den Web-Servern, also worauf Wikileaks läuft, dass ihr irgendwie Angriffe hattet oder halt auch deutsch gehackt wurdet?
Ja, also wir sind relativ häufig Opfer von irgendwem, der versucht, sich ein bisschen an unsere Infrastruktur auszutoben oder ein bisschen zu eruieren, was möglich ist oder nicht. Also wir sehen das ja auch. Nach unserer Kenntnis ist bisher noch nie kompromittiert worden. Das heißt, es hat noch keine erfolgreiche irgendwas gehackt, zumindest soweit wir das sagen können. Dazu kommt, dass wir das alles so strukturiert haben, dass selbst wenn eine Komponente wie der Web-Server kompromittiert würde, dass es keine keine praktische Konsequenz hat für die Sicherheit von irgendjemandem. Das heißt, der Web-Server zum Beispiel sieht überhaupt keine IP-Adressen von irgendwelchen Nutzern. Das ist alles auf dem Weg zum Web-Server in unserem Netzwerk schon längst anonymisiert. Das heißt, der Web-Server sieht irgendwelche Bogus-IP-Adressen, die nicht zu dem eigentlichen Besucher einer Seite gehört oder zu demjenigen, der gerade was hochlädt.
Und wie sieht das jetzt aus, wenn ihr zum Beispiel irgendwas veröffentlicht und jemand sagt, man muss ja nicht sein, dass diejenigen unbedingt an die IP-Adressen ran sind, sondern einfach nicht will, dass dieses Dokument publiziert wird. Und sagen wir jetzt einfach mal, die DDoS ist ja leider ziemlich bekannt und könnt ihr da auch vorgehen gegen oder seid ihr da auch wehrlos?
Na ja, wir sind, natürlich gibt es immer technische Einschränkungen gegen sowas wie ein DDoS, sich zu wehren. Ist jetzt, sag ich mal, unter Umständen nicht unbedingt trivial. Kommt drauf an, wie viel Bandbreite dahinter steckt oder so. Aber das sind auch keine Probleme, die wir in der Praxis bisher so hatten. Wir haben auch alternativ dazu verschiedenste Einstiegspunkte an verschiedenen Teilen der Welt. Also wir können auch ausweichen, falls jetzt eine Leitung komplett von irgendjemandem blockiert wird, der gerade ein bisschen zu viel Energie hat oder so. Ja, also wobei das auch bisher zum Glück realistischerweise kein Problem ist. Ich schiebe das ein bisschen darauf, dass das, was wir machen, innerhalb der technischen Community, die sowas machen könnte, relativ anerkannt ist und deswegen eigentlich niemand von den Leuten, die es machen könnten, irgendwas gegen uns hat.
Ihr verliert ja auch kein Geld daran. Also diese Denial-of-Service-Attacken, die sind da, wenn sie jetzt gegen Firmen, weiß nicht, gegen Amazon oder sonst wen, es ist ja bei denen, jede Minute, die die nicht erreichbar sind, ist ja da einfach richtig Kohle was flöten geht, wenn die Leute da nichts kaufen können. Und es ist ja bei Wikileaks nicht der Fall, weil da geht es ja jetzt in dem Sinne nicht um Geld und Umsatz. Die sind dann halt mal eine Weile schwer zu erreichen, aber dann wird es dann irgendwann auch langweilig.
Also wir haben schon auch, das haben ja die meisten, die unsere Webseite vielleicht länger verfolgen, schon bemerkt, gelegentlich mal Ressourcenengpässe, so dass eine Leitung dicht ist und wir eine Splashpage zeigen müssen, dass wir zu viele Besucher haben gerade. Aber das sind halt Sachen, die kommen auch mit unserer Beta-Phasenstellung momentan. Also einfach weil das, was implementiert ist, ist so eine Art Minimal-Set, um das abzubilden, was wir machen wollen. Und das wird hoffentlich mit dem Release 1.0, über den wir vielleicht dann später noch ein bisschen reden, sind solche Sachen dann eigentlich auch ausgeschlossen. Beziehungsweise stehen wir etwas besser da.
Viel größeres Problem als Denial-of-Service-Attacken. Also Angriffe mit dem Ziel, eure Serverlärm zu legen, sind ja wahrscheinlich eher Bemühungen von Regierungen, von Firmen, auch durch Anwälte, euch zu stoppen.
Ja, also die rechtliche Seite ist da, denke ich, auch wesentlich problematischer als auf so einer technischen Ebene. Oder was heißt so wirklich problematisch, ist es ja eigentlich auch nicht, weil die bisher alle irgendwo ins Leere laufen.
Das heißt, es ist noch nicht so weit, dass ihr die Hälfte des Tages damit verbringt, Dokumente zu sichten und auf Echtheit zu prüfen und die andere Hälfte des Tages den technischen Ablauf oben zu halten, euch gegen Anwälte zu wehren?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir können uns zum Glück sehr stark Dokumenten widmen.
Haben wir deine Frage beantwortet?
Jetzt geht es hier gleich weiter, nächster am Telefon ist David. Guten Abend, David.
Ich habe auch eine Frage an euch, so ein bisschen was rechtliches. Ihr habt ja bestimmt Erfahrungen, wie das ist. Ihr habt ja schon gesagt, ihr werdet regelmäßig Leute, die euch mit Klagen drohen, irgendwie macht das weg, macht das weg. Und ich möchte halt als Privatperson, wäre das für mich natürlich schwierig, irgendwie gegen so eine Klagewelle anzukommen. Weil, worauf ich hinausfälle, ist, dass ich mir wünsche, ich möchte mir irgendwann so eine Diskussion auf der Seite machen. Und auf der mal halt, das soll eine Diskussionsplattform werden für Leute, wo ich halt irgendwie alles groß und in die Meinungsfreiheit irgendwie deklarieren möchte, klar. Und da gibt es dann bestimmt auch den einen oder anderen, der eine Meinung vertritt, die irgendwie verfassungswidrig ist, wie auch immer. Und ich möchte halt solche Leute, klar, ich möchte es nicht da haben, aber ich möchte sie auch nicht davon ausschließen. Also wie das halt ist, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Leute meinen, sie müssen jetzt irgendwelche antisemitischen Standpunkte verteidigen oder so ein Shit, dann will ich ihnen halt die Möglichkeit geben, dass sie halt sich einer offenen Diskussion stellen können. Und da kann das natürlich auch dann in der Diskussion sehr schmutzig werden und da können bestimmt auch Leute sich dadurch gestört fühlen. Und da wäre meine Frage, was jeder denkt, wie das für mich als Privatperson wäre, ob ich da irgendwie groß was befürchten muss oder ob ich das halt wie in so einem Internetforum sagen kann, ich bin nur der Inhaber der Seite, da bin ich nicht verantwortlich.
Das ist also eine sehr komplizierte Frage.
Als Privatperson ist es zumindest schon mal eine schlechte Idee, das zu machen. Weil dann erst mal hast du, auch wenn es vielleicht, sage ich mal, im Endeffekt gut ausgeht, aber du hast natürlich erst mal den ganzen Ärger an der Backe, der halt irgendwie von Klagen, Anwaltsrechnungen, Hausdurchsuchungen, weiß nicht was gehen kann, wenn man dir einen Karren fahren will. Und insofern würde ich mir das schon überlegen, ob du das als Privatperson machen willst oder ob du dir vielleicht irgendeinen Verein gründen willst, ein paar Mitstreiter suchst, dass ihr da einfach eine rechtlich bessere Basis habt.
Okay, also das heißt, aber prinzipiell kann man das so sagen irgendwie, weil es gab ja irgendwann mal so ein Internetforum halt auch so Sachen, dass halt irgendwie die Webmasse, wenn man halt irgendwie so ein Disclaimer davor setzt, ich registriere mich hier auf der Plattform, ich bin mir bewusst, dass...
Naja, also da solltest du auf jeden Fall mal einen Juristen fragen. Letztendlich, ich meine so eine Diskussion, ich meine, schau dir irgendwie StudiVZ an, da gibt es auch regelmäßig irgendwelche, sage ich mal, zumindest grenzwertige Äußerungen. Und ja, da gibt es auch genauso viele Leute, die irgendwie das Scheiße finden, dass die da sind und auch darauf bestehen, dass es da wieder wegkommt. Aber ich denke mal, das führt auch ein kleines bisschen vom Thema ab.
Also was ich dir anbieten kann ist, du kannst mir eine Mail schreiben, daniel.wikileaks.org und kannst vielleicht mal kurz schildern, was du da genau vorhast und dann können wir ja sehen, ob sich vielleicht was ergibt, was man dir raten kann oder so.
Also wenn du bis jetzt noch keinen Stress in deinem Leben hast, dann mach das und du wirst sehr schnell graue Haare kriegen und sonstige Geschichten.
Dann kann ich einfach mal probieren, das irgendwie in Worte zu fassen, schriftlich und eine Mail rüberzuschreiben.
Alles klar, danke schön.
Wollen wir gleich weitermachen? John ist am Telefon. Hallo John, guten Abend.
Hallo. Guten Abend. Ich wollte mich eigentlich bedanken, nur bedanken für die Wikileaks, also ihr macht das echt super, so ein Projekt vorzurufen finde ich echt super. Und da auch so viel Zeit und Geld und Nerven zu investieren, finde ich einfach genial von euch.
Danke.
Nutzt du Wikileaks selber persönlich auch?
Ja, ich guck da halt ab und zu rein oder ich seh, wenn ich irgendwo News lese, halt links zu Wikileaks, wo dann eben die News sich auf so einen Leak bezieht. Und finde ich einfach super, da hat man halt so was wie Media nur für noch krassere Informationen sozusagen.
Ja danke, dafür machen wir es.
So direktes Feedback gibt es ja dann eigentlich auch nicht, wenn ihr da ein Dokument braucht.
Ja das ist immer schön zu hören. Das ist ähnlich wie mit Island auch, dass wir haben so viele Mails bekommen, in denen uns Leute sich bedankt haben für das, was wir machen. Und das ist auch das, was meine Motivation ist, diese Sache weiter zu machen. Das baut einen halt auch zwischen dem ganzen Stress immer weiter auf.
Du hast jetzt eine ganze Weile darüber gesprochen, wie Dokumente zu euch kommen und wie ihr die prüft und dass sie veröffentlicht werdet. Wie ist denn dann der Weitergang der Dinge? Also gibt es dann Leute wie John, Leute wie wir, Journalisten, Presse, Nachrichtenagenturen, die sich dann auf euch beziehen, bei euch anrufen, die echt das Dokument fordern oder wissen wollen und daraus dann die Story weiter drehen und sich auf euch beziehen?
Ja, also in der Regel wird das dann, wenn wir jetzt von Medien sprechen, wird das von Zeitungen oder Online-Medien oder vom Fernsehen oder wie auch immer aufgegriffen. Und die benutzen dieses Dokument dann eben so, wie sie ein Dokument benutzen, das eine ihrer Journalisten eben zugespielt bekommen hat. Daraus entstehen dann die vielfältigsten Sachen. Und neben den ganzen Medien benutzen das auch zum Beispiel Anwälte, wo wir wieder bei Guantanamo sind, für die Verteidigung von den ganzen Gefangenen in Guantanamo. Die Anwälte, die dort vor Gericht für diese Menschen kämpfen, nutzen die Dokumente, die wir publiziert haben, aktiv, um eben Menschenrechtsverletzungen nachzuweisen. Das ist für die verschiedensten Menschen auf dieser Welt einfach von Nutzen.
Ich habe mal noch eine Frage, was einfach rein die Namensgebung angeht. Was habt ihr einmal mit Wikipedia vielleicht zu tun? Und es gibt auch noch eine Seite, die heißt Live Leaks, auch vom Namen ähnlich.
Ja, also der Leak, das Leck an sich als englisches Wort, ist eben das, wie wir Dokumente verstehen, die zu uns kommen. Also es gibt irgendwo einen Informationsleck und daraus entsteht eben ein Dokument oder daraus der Ursprung für ein Dokument, das bei uns auftaucht. Die Idee mit dem Wiki ist im Moment etwas, das aus den früheren Zeiten des Projekts einfach noch übrig ist. Die ganz einfache idealistische, sehr idealistische Idee hinter diesem Projekt war, dass wir gesagt haben, wir möchten so etwas wie den ersten öffentlichen Geheimdienst gründen. Also der Öffentlichkeit jedem Bürger ermöglichen, in einem Intelligence-Dienst beteiligt zu sein, der so viel mehr Informationen akkumulieren kann als jeder staatliche Geheimdienst, dass er einfach viel mächtiger wird. Und wir wollten eben sicherstellen, dass auch die Öffentlichkeit in diesem ganzen Intelligence-Business eben ihre Position hat und vertreten ist. Und die Möglichkeit hat eben auch, mit Informationen zu arbeiten. Und da war ganz am Anfang eben die Idee, dass Wikipedia ist eine der Oberflächen, die die meisten Leute im Internet kennen. Also auch Leute, die nicht besonders technisch versiert sind oder so, sondern man kennt eben dieses Interface vom MediaWiki. Und wir haben versucht, es daran anzulehnen, um Anreize zu schaffen, damit sich möglichst viele Leute aus der breiten Öffentlichkeit eben auf diesem Portal involvieren. Das ist mittlerweile ein bisschen durch die Realität korrigiert.
Aber der Name bleibt.
Ja, zumindest Wikileaks selbst ist ja auch, da kommen wir auch vielleicht dann später nochmal drauf, auch nur einen Teilaspekt, eine etwas größere Überlegung, die wir eigentlich haben.
Na lass uns doch darüber mal reden. Du hast schon gesagt, es ist jetzt eine Beta und da kommt irgendwann ein 1.0. Wie würde es denn aussehen, wenn du dir das jetzt mal zusammenbasteln könntest? Und wohin soll es gehen?
Wikileaks selbst ist, sag ich mal, ein Aspekt von etwas, das wir die Sunshine Press nennen. Das heißt, es ist eine Institution, die verschiedenste Sachen publiziert, unter anderem eben die Wikileaks-Plattform. Wir haben eine ganze Menge Ideen, wie man das, was in diesem ganzen Umfeld entsteht, eben noch weiter nutzen könnte. Zum Beispiel würden wir, das ist was, was mit Release 1.0 kommen wird, werden wir für Zeitungen oder überhaupt für jeden, der online zum Beispiel eine Webseite betreibt, betreibt ein Code-Snippet, bereitstellen, dass man bei sich auf der Webseite implementieren kann. Und das bringt quasi unsere Submission-Methode auf diese Webseite. Das heißt, jede Zeitung könnte irgendwo eine Submission-Form haben, die ein Leser dieser Zeitung oder ein Besucher nutzen kann, um ein Dokument zu verschicken. Das würde direkt an uns geschickt. Und wir können über den Referrer dann sehen, dass es von dieser Zeitung kam. Und könnten dann der Zeitung das Exklusivrecht zum Beispiel für eine oder zwei Wochen auf dieses Dokument geben. Die Zeitung würde profitieren, weil sie das Dokument bekommt, weil sie keine rechtlichen Probleme hat, weil wir dieses Dokument dann publizieren. Und sie hätte Exklusivrecht daran. Ein weiterer Vorteil wäre, dass zum Beispiel der Leser seine Zeitung unterstützen könnte. Lokale Dokumente, die jetzt, sagen wir, irgendwo in der Kleinstadt zum Beispiel relevant sind, auch den entsprechenden Medien sehr einfach zugespielt werden könnten. Und es entsteht so was wie eine Interaktion eben, auch zwischen der Öffentlichkeit und den Zeitungen und uns. Das ist so eine der Überlegungen. Eine andere Überlegung ist, dass wir zum Beispiel sehr gerne so was wie ein Peer Review Journal rausgeben möchten. Also wirklich gedruckt als Magazin. Im Sinne von dem, was es in der Wissenschaft auch gibt. Wir möchten gerne die Möglichkeit bieten, dass jemand, der eine akademische Laufbahn verfolgt, Material von uns für seine akademische Laufbahn publizieren kann oder analysieren kann. Darüber dann ein Paper schreibt, was er in diesem Peer Review Journal veröffentlicht. Und wir eben somit die Akademiker einbinden können, um Sachen zu analysieren, die für unser heutiges Leben relevant sind. Und ihnen die Möglichkeit bieten, das in ihre akademische Laufbahn mit einzubinden. Es sind ziemlich viele verschiedene Überlegungen. Also es gibt noch wesentlich mehr Beispiele von Sachen, die wir uns gerne vorstellen könnten oder die wir gerne sehen möchten. Aber es scheitert eigentlich im Moment alles daran, dass wir eben die Ressourcen dafür bereitstellen müssen. Und der Release 1.0, den wir so für Richtung Ende des Jahres geplant haben, zum Beispiel, braucht 30 bis 35 neue Maschinen, die wir irgendwo von irgendwem bekommen müssen. Also es geht dann weniger um die Hardware, sondern um die Kosten im Monat.
Okay, wenn Leute hören jetzt zu, sagen, finde ich super, ich habe irgendwie gerade im Lotto gewonnen, kann euch ein paar Maschinen sponsern. Wie kann ich damit euch in Verbindung treten und das machen?
Ja, also wir haben ja den Chat zum Beispiel. Man kann über unseren Chat besuchen, das ist ein IRC-Chat, für den es auch im Webfront entgibt, das SSL verschlüsselt ist. Man kann sich über Mail mit uns in Kontakt treten. Wir sind hier auf vielen Konferenzen und so auch, wo technisch orientierte Leute sind unterwegs. Im Endeffekt, was wichtig ist zu wissen, ist, dass wir gerne den Leuten die Möglichkeit geben möchten, so ähnlich wie der CCC das auch mit den Tor-Servern plant, ja sowas wie eine Patenschaft zu übernehmen. Dass man sagt, ich möchte 50 Euro im Monat, ist mir das wert. Und dafür sponsor ich das Betreiben von einem Server. Das verursacht keine weitere Mehrarbeit für irgendwen. Also man muss sich nicht um die Maintenance von dem Server kümmern oder so. Und vor allem verursacht es auch keine rechtlichen Probleme. Denn die Server, die wir alle betreiben, sind in einem privaten Verbund. Keiner dieser Server wird direkt ins Internet exponiert. Man sieht diese IP-Adresse nicht. Also es gibt keine rechtlichen Schritte gegen die Betreiber von unseren Servern. Das ist alles in diesem Konstrukt, wie wir das aufgebaut haben, eben gewährleistet. Und deswegen ist es eigentlich sehr einfach, uns zu unterstützen. Es ist halt nur sehr zeitintensiv, zum einen Leute zu finden, die verlässlich sind, und zum anderen eben, sage ich mal, gewisse organisationstechnische Sachen zu entwickeln. Und eben solche Ideen wie unser Peer-Revisional oder auch dieses Code-Snippets usw. eben bereitzustellen.
Braucht ihr, jetzt haben wir zum einen gesagt, ihr braucht Leute, die Server hosten, die euch finanziell unterstützen. Braucht ihr auch noch Manpower, also Leute, die euch...
Klar.
Tatkräftig unterstützen, wenn nicht wie bei der Wikipedia, dass Leute also Artikel quer lesen, die gegenrecherchieren. Weil es könnt ihr ja nicht alleine stemmen, wenn es immer größer wird.
Also jeder, der das, was wir machen, gerne unterstützen möchte und in irgendeiner Art und Weise was kann, ist eigentlich von Nutzen für uns. Das können Leute sein, die bestimmte Fachbereiche abdecken können bei der Verifizierung von Dokumenten, einfach weil sie da Expertise haben.
Das ist vor allem wichtig gerade aus dem Nicht-Computer-Bereich.
Wir können Hilfe aus allen Schichten dieser Gesellschaft brauchen. Wir brauchen Leute, die gewisse Teile der Plattform in alle Sprachen übersetzen. Es ist sehr wichtig, dass zum Beispiel die Submission-Guidelines, die Beschreibungen für Risiko, die ganzen Informationen, die wir potenziellen Quellen zum Beispiel geben, dass sowas muttersprachlich verfügbar ist. Weil das wichtig ist, dass Leute das hundertprozentig verstehen können und den Zugang auch direkt dazu finden. Genauso haben wir sehr viel Entwicklungsarbeit, also Code-Arbeit, die erledigt werden muss. Wenn jetzt jemand zuhört, der gerne C-Programmierung nah am BSD-Könnel macht und ein bisschen was an Zeit frei hat, wir könnten sehr gut Leute gebrauchen. Genauso für verschiedenste Entwicklungsaufgaben im Ruby-Umfeld oder so. Und das sind alles Sachen, die es noch nicht gibt. Und das sind alles Sachen, von denen man, wenn man dabei hilft, sieht, dass sie was Positives bewirken. Es ist ein greifbares Ergebnis. Es sind Sachen, die direkten Einfluss nehmen auf das, was wir machen können und das, was wir auf unserem Portal offerieren können. Der Befriedigungswert ist auch extrem hoch.
Sag einmal eine Kontaktadresse und du hast die nächsten 14 Tage zu tun, Mails zu lesen.
Die Kontaktadressen sind alle auch im Wiki. Wer links bei Contact us schaut, findet die Kontaktadressen. Ansonsten wäre das wl-tech at sunshinepress.org. Ist eigentlich die Adresse für jeden, der uns technisch unterstützen mag. Es gibt auch wl-supporters at sunshinepress.org und so weiter.
Aber du findest das schon.
Da findet sich jeder zurecht.
Und im Zweifelsfall fragt er einfach beim CCC nach.
0331 77 97 110 Telefonnummer vom Chaosradio hier auf Fritz. Und wir haben Arne am Telefon. Hallo Arne, guten Abend. Ist schon nicht schlafen, oder was? Klingst ein bisschen verpennt, großer.
Ich war halt unterwegs, hab ein bisschen Sport gemacht und dann ist man ein bisschen fertig. Nee, ich hab ne Frage, ich erzähl gar nicht. Und zwar, ihr redet ja davon, dass alles unglaublich anonyme ist. Das ist ja auch vollkommen richtig so, wenn anders wäre es so irgendwie scheiße. Aber was ich mich jetzt frage ist, ich meine, ihr veröffentlichte irgendwelche, ich schätze mal Berichte, die mehr oder weniger entfernt auch sind. Ich gehe immer davon aus, dass in diesen Berichten ja eigentlich auch Namen genannt werden. Prinzipiell müsste ja, wenn alles anonym wäre, eben auch entsprechend diese Berichte auch anonymisiert werden. Ich meine, dass der das dahinspielt, das ist klar, dass der anonym ist, aber ich meine, irgendwo müsste es ja, also wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass da was veröffentlicht wird, dass das gleiche teilweise auch die Persönlichkeitsrechte von den Leuten an, die darin irgendwie genannt werden, oder?
Das ist natürlich immer eine Frage. Allerdings, wenn jemand in einem Dokument, aus unserer Sicht, in einem Dokument genannt ist, dass ein bestimmten Sachverhalt, der in der Realität stattfindet, der von einem öffentlichen Interesse ist, wenn da ein Name genannt wird, dann ist dieses öffentliche Interesse in zumindest den Fällen, die mir bisher bekannt sind, größer als das Persönlichkeitsrecht von demjenigen, der im Dokument genannt wird.
Wobei wir natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen das Henne-Ei-Problem dabei haben. Das heißt also, in dem Moment, wo es bei euch auf Wikileaks ist, dann wird natürlich auch ein öffentliches Interesse wahrscheinlich erst draus, was möglicherweise vorher noch gar nicht da ist. Das Problem haben wir aber auch genauso bei den Medien, bei Stars. Wenn es darum geht, dass die Paparazzi den Leuten hinterherstiefelt und Fotos schießt, während sie am Pool liegen, ist natürlich bei gewissen Leuten erst dann relevant, wenn sie auch einen gewissen Grad in Öffentlichkeit erreicht haben. Aber das ist so eine Sache, die sich auch aufbaut und wahrscheinlich die Grenze auch ein bisschen schwimmt.
Das ist natürlich eine sehr komplexe Frage. Wir müssen auch bei vielen Dokumenten zum Beispiel berücksichtigen, dass Namen, die im Dokument genannt werden, natürlich auch vielleicht jemandem wie die Quelle exponieren können. Aber das sind Sachen, wo wir halt auch zum einen mit der Quelle zusammenarbeiten können. Die Quelle kann uns auch sagen, dass sie zum Beispiel darum bittet, dass ein Dokument redigiert wird. Das ist auch was, was wir machen. Also wenn die Quelle darum bittet, bestimmte Informationen, die Persönlichkeitsrechte betreffen, aus Gründen, die die Quelle hat, dass das redigiert werden soll, dann können wir dabei auch helfen. Und wir haben eben auch die Erfahrung, das so zu machen, dass niemand hinterher diese Redigierung wieder rückgängig machen kann.
Also das heißt eigentlich, dass wenn jemand hier sagt, ich möchte, dass der Name daran zum Beispiel abgeändert wird, würde die das auch machen?
Ja, das kommt natürlich ein bisschen auf den Sachverhalt an, aber in der Regel ist das schon was, was wir mit der Quelle verhandeln können. Oder wo wir die Quelle unterstützen, sage ich mal, gewisse Sachen zu beschützen.
Das ist natürlich gut, wenn denn die Quelle das eigentliche Problem ist, die dann damit wieder gedeckt wird.
Ja, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch sehr theoretisch.
Wahrscheinlich diskutiert sich das immer nur am konkreten Fall ganz genau und jetzt wenig an so einem hypothetischen Beispiel, was auch was rumspiegt.
Okay, dann noch gerade eine andere Frage. Bisher war ja immer von irgendwelchen Dingen die Rede von Firmen, von irgendwelchen Staatssicherheitssachen. Aber ist es nicht auch so, dass da teilweise irgendwelche Sachen, Leute aus irgendwelchen Bereichen, aus irgendwelchen Szenen da rein posten, die vielleicht auch von uns her sind? Also ist das Angebot, aber die Information, die da befindet, die ausschließlich begrenzt auf eben entsprechende...
Nein, das ist gesteuert über das, was Leute uns schicken. Nicht über das, was wir sagen, was wir gerne haben wollen.
Ja, aber die Frage ist sowas da auch zu finden.
Was denn für Szenen?
Ja, mein Gott, weiß ich, aber man stellt sich vor, man ist als Journalist auf der Suche nach einem Artikel über irgendwelche Untergrundszenen, zum Beispiel eine Graffiti-Szene. Dann wäre Wikileaks ein Anlaufpunkt, um eben auch da was zu finden.
Also zur Graffiti-Szene haben wir nichts. Das kann ich jetzt praktisch so sagen. Ansonsten ist die Frage halt leider etwas hypothetisch so. Das ist immer schwierig. Die Leute schicken uns verschiedenste Sachen. Du könntest jetzt auch sagen, wir haben zum Beispiel jetzt vor anderthalb Wochen 627 E-Mails von einem E-Mail-Verteiler der nationalsozialistischen amerikanischen Partei publiziert. Das ist eine gewisse Szene. Zu der Szene, der Nazis in den USA, findest du bei uns jetzt Informationen.
Da wollen wir vielleicht bei dem Spray am Beispiel bleiben. Es wäre natürlich schon blöd, wenn jetzt auf Wikileaks die Mitgliederlisten der fünf größten Sprühergruppen in Berlin auftauchen. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur hypothetisch.
Es hätte überhaupt niemand, der diese Listen kennt, hätte ein Interesse, sowas zu submitten. Das kommt ja auch immer dazu. Die Arbeit, das ist ja auch eine Frage, wie viel Arbeit mache ich mir? Was für eine Motivation habe ich überhaupt, das zu machen? Das ist eine rein ökonomische Frage wieder.
Also musst du dir keine Sorgen machen, Arno, du stehst noch nicht im Netz.
Die Frage ist ja durchaus berechtigt. Wir haben das ja auch schon viel diskutiert, auch im Vorfeld der Sendung. Das war ja eigentlich auch ein bisschen unser Diskussionsansatz. Gibt es da wirklich irgendwo Grenzen? Gibt es irgendwelche Sachen, die jetzt einfach nicht veröffentlicht werden sollten, weil sie eben Persönlichkeitsrechte berühren? Wenn da jetzt nicht dieses öffentliche Interesse drüber steht, dann gäbe es ja auch möglicherweise einen guten Grund, die dann tatsächlich auch nicht zu veröffentlichen.
Ja, aber insofern stehen meine Fragen ja auch im Zusammenhang. Denn wenn man eben aus öffentlichen Interessen, wie großen Firmen, Banken etc. hinausgeht, geht es auch aus anderen Gebieten, glaube ich. Da kommen wir an diese Eckpunkte. Aber ich glaube, ich habe jetzt eher verstanden, dass es so läuft, dass so etwas gar nicht existiert, weil gar kein Interesse daran hat, so etwas abzuladen.
Zumindest praktisch bisher.
Und was da in der Zukunft passiert, werden wir alles sehen. Danke dir für eine Anrufe, Anne. Wir machen jetzt kurz Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es weiter mit James. Leg nicht auf, bleib dran, wir wollen auch mit dir reden.
Vor ein paar Jahren spielten sie eines der legendärsten Radiokonzerte aller Zeiten live in den Fritz-Studios. Jetzt hätten wir fast keinen Ort gefunden, wo alle reinpassen, die sie sehen wollen.
Donnerstag, 29.
Oktober. News, live in der Haute-Wolle-Berlin. Karten gibt's über, wo's Karten gibt, aber zusammen mit mehr Infos auch auf fritzee. News, pünktlich zum neuen Album in Berlin. Fast pünktlich. Und das wird man.
Aber wir sind pünktlich halb zwölf.
Gesundheitsministerin Ola Schmidt muss nach ihrer Dienstwagen-Affäre vorerst nicht mit Konsequenzen rechnen. Nach der Befragung durch den Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages sagte sie, es seien alle Richtlinien beachtet und die privat gefahrenen Kilometer gesondert abgerechnet worden. Auch Wirtschaftsminister zu Guttenberg musste sich wegen eines umstrittenen Auftrages in eine Anwaltskanzlei rechtfertigen. Er wies darauf hin, dass das Ministerium auf externe Beratung angewiesen war, weil bei der Entwicklung eines Bankengesetzes die Kompetenz gefehlt hätte. In Lindo bei Neuropien haben sich zwei Gruppen von Jugendlichen heute geprügelt. Die 15 einheimischen Jugendlichen sollen eine Gruppe türkestämmiger Jugendlicher aus Berlin ausländerfeindlich beschimpft haben. Außerdem kamen unter anderem Baseballschläger zum Einsatz. Zwei Personen wurden verletzt. Die türkestämmigen Jugendlichen waren mit ihrem Fußballverein für ein Trainingslager in Lindo. Das haben sie am Abend auf eigenen Wunsch verlassen. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel will sich für internationale Regeln einsetzen, um Bonuszahlungen an Banker zu begrenzen. Sie unterstützt damit einen Vorschlag von Frankreichs Präsident Sarkozy. Die CDU-Chefin sagte, es sei ärgerlich, dass viele Banken bei den Bonuszahlungen so weitermachten wie vor der Finanzkrise. Der französische Präsident Sarkozy hatte vorgeschlagen, Bonuszahlungen bei Fehlleistungen auch nachträglich noch zu kürzen. Sie sollten zudem nicht auf einmal, sondern zeitlich gestreckt ausbezahlt werden. Der VfB Stuttgart hat den Einzug in die Champions League geschafft. Im Rückspiel gegen den rumänischen Gegner FC Timisoara reichte Stuttgart ein 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Neben Wolfsburg und den Bayern ist Stuttgart die dritte deutsche Mannschaft in der Champions League. Und Fußball-Zweitligist Union Berlin hat in dem Freundschaftsspiel gegen Bayern München verloren. Am Ende stand es 1 zu 3. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Wittenberge 14 Grad, Neuropäen 15, Angermünde 16, Potsdam-Corpus, Frankfurt 20 Grad und in Berlin zwischen 17 und 22 Grad. Orten Nacht gibt's nur ein paar Wolken, kaum Regen ist dabei. Und die Temperaturen sinken noch auch bis zu 12 Grad. Tagsüber ist es dann wieder schön sonnig und warm, nur wenig Wolken. Es bleibt auch meistens trocken bei maximal 30 Grad. A115 Zubringer Nutetal statt einwärts Richtung Berlin zwischen Dreieck-Mutetal und Sammund. Da steht ein defekter Lkw, hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. Dann die A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Hafeland zwischen Leest und Potsdam Nord. Da gibt's ebenfalls Behinderungen durch ein defektes Fahrzeug. Dann die A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen dem Rastplatz Schwielosee und der Raststätte am Fichtenplan Süd. Da fährt ein Schwertransport und es gibt Behinderungen. Und A24 Berlin Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Dreieck-Wittstock, Dosse und Suko ebenfalls ein Schwertransport. An dem kommt ihr nicht vorbei. Ansonsten Rolls.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Leute, was für eine spannende Sendung. Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 149. Daniel Schmidt ist bei uns von Wikileaks, Frank Rosengard vom CCC ist auch bei uns, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir haben auch eine halbe Stunde Zeit über Wikileaks zu reden, denn nichts am Telefon ist James. Koffe, du bist, ist okay, dass du jetzt noch ein bisschen warten musstest, Nachrichten müssen ja pünktlich sein.
Äh, ehrlich gesagt, es ist echt eine oberspannende Sendung, es ist richtig krass. Also ich höre jetzt seit anderthalb Stunden gut zu, so. Sehr aufmerksam und das einzige Wort, was mir zu den Männern einfällt, die so motiviert und so kompetent dabei sind, ist einfach Respekt.
Vielen Dank.
So krass, also aus tiefstem Herzen Respekt. Das ist wirklich ganz krass.
Ja, das hören wir bestimmt gerne.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wir sind sprachlos und bedanken uns zurück.
Hast du sonst noch Fragen, die wir dir beantworten können oder magst du sonst noch was?
Wenn nicht, habe ich nämlich noch Fragen ohne Ende.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es ja so, dass das, was ihr macht, ist ja sozusagen das, was das System mit uns macht, nur mit der Ausnahme, dass ihr es halt nicht irgendwie verschleiert.
Genau das ist Sinn der Sache. Ja, wir machen weiter.
Wir lassen James noch ein bisschen geflasht.
Ich wünsche euch alles Gute und ich wünsche euch alle Hilfe, die ihr kriegen könnt. Und ich wünsche euch alles, alles, alles, alles Gute.
Ich habe nämlich noch ein paar Fragen. Wir haben noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen. Wenn ich angenommen, ich möchte Wikileaks-Dokumente schicken, die ich habe, auf was muss ich denn da achten? Wie müssen die beschaffen sein? Gibt es da technische Hinweise, die ich brauche, um auch mich als Quelle zu schützen?
Vielleicht noch mal so einen ganz kleinen Exkurs in die analoge Vergangenheit. Es gibt ja schon oder es gibt immer noch die Möglichkeiten, wenn ich Dokumente habe, die ich gern an die Öffentlichkeit kommen lassen möchte, möglichst. Das sind allerdings leider nicht so ganz zuverlässige Sachen. Also die eine, das ist ein ganz beliebter alter Trick, ist der Trick mit dem Schließfach im Bahnhof, wo man dann einfach die Sachen einschließt und weggeht und einfach den Schlüssel wegwirft. Und dann wird das Ding irgendwann dann vom Service geöffnet und dann finden sich da brisante Sachen drin. Das ist eine sehr beliebte Sache gewesen. Dann natürlich auch der Klassiker, die geheime Übergabe an Journalisten, sind dann die Dokumente, die im Müll einmal gelandet sind, anstatt im Papierschredder. Das kommt auch mal wieder vor, dass so Dokumente gefunden werden oder dass zumindestens die Story das ist. Und natürlich auch ganz klassisch der einfachste Weg, der braune Umschlag ohne Absender drauf, der dann irgendwie bei der Redaktion landet.
Also in der Art und Weise, wir haben verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man uns Dokumente zukommen lassen kann. Also ganz klassisch, wie der Frank das ja gerade gesagt hat, wir haben überall auf der Welt verteilt Postfächer, die von Leuten unterhalten werden für uns. Das heißt, man kann einfach anonym irgendetwas ausdrucken, einwerfen, das kommt bei uns irgendwo an, wir scannen das wieder ein, verarbeiten das weiter, digitalisieren das und so weiter. Das ist so die Failsafe-Methode, wo eigentlich fast nichts schief gehen kann. Durch den ganzen Prozess, dass es wieder gescannt wird, digitalisiert wird und so weiter, kann man auch viele Probleme umgehen, was die Markierungen dieser Dokumente angeht. Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel Markierungskennzeichen auf Dokumenten, die auf Farbdruckern oder sowas ausgedruckt wurden, also diese gelben Dots, die Yellowdots, die es da gibt. Zum Beispiel dadurch, dass es wieder gescannt wird, von unserer Seite wird zum Beispiel sichergestellt, dass diese Yellowdots nicht mehr da sind.
Was machen diese Yellowdots?
Also ganz kurzer Exkurs, ist es so, dass seit vielen Jahren schon, wir haben das vor vier Jahren, fünf Jahren ungefähr hier in Deutschland, bei den Big Brother Awards auch schon aufgedeckt, die jetzt übrigens am 16. Oktober verliehen werden wieder, dass viele Geräte, vor allem Farbkopierer, das ist als erstes aufgetreten, aber mittlerweile auch praktisch alle Farbdrucker, hinterlassen kleine, praktisch unsichtbare Spuren auf dem Papier. Und diese Spuren beinhalten Informationen über das Gerät, mit der diese Seite gedruckt worden ist. Das heißt also eine Seriennummer, teilweise sogar auch schon ein Datum. Das heißt also, es ist anhand von Vergleichen, von Dokumenten, von Ausdrucken ziemlich gut nachverfolgbar, wo dieses Dokument gedruckt, ausgedruckt worden ist oder kopiert worden ist. Das ist leider kaum bekannt. Die Hersteller sind da auch nicht so richtig kooperativ gewesen. Und das muss man immer wissen, dass also alle Farbdrucke, Farbausdrucke, Farbkopien zurückverfolgbar sind.
Also ich denke, dass wir, das denke ich kann ich so sagen mittlerweile, wir haben eine extrem große Expertise entwickelt, was das Behandeln von verschiedensten Dokumenten betrifft. Sowohl was den Ursprung dieser Dokumente angeht, wie auch die Art und Weise, wie wir das bekommen. Und wir sind sehr stark darauf spezialisiert, diese Dokumente eben vernünftig zu anonymisieren. Jedes Dokument, das bei uns ankommt, wird technisch gesäubert. Also das, was wir publizieren, beinhaltet keine Metadaten mehr, die irgendjemand auswerten kann. Wir stellen sicher, dass wenn wir was scannen zum Beispiel, dass es von der Auflösung her so niedrig ist, dass sowas wie diese Yellowdots gar nicht mehr erkennbar sind. Das sind verschiedenste Sachen, die man einfach berücksichtigen kann. Was wichtig ist, ist, dass die Leute, dass jemand, der ein Dokument hat, das wichtig ist, versteht, dass man es richtig machen muss. Das ist die größte Gefahr bei der ganzen Sache. Wir haben viele Beispiele gehabt oder zumindest ein paar Beispiele, wo Leute uns was geschickt haben und haben es dann selbst denselben Inhalt, den sie uns geschickt haben, nochmal woanders publiziert, weil sie in irgendeiner Art und Weise in einem Forum damit angeben wollten, dass sie sowas haben oder so. Das bedeutet, dass jemand ein Originaldokument woanders hingeschoben hat. Bei uns wurde dann die anonymisierte Version publiziert, mit der gibt es keine Probleme, aber es gab Leute, die dafür ertappt wurden oder in Schwierigkeiten gekommen sind, weil eben ihre Originaldokumente irgendwo aufgetaucht sind. Es ist wichtig zu verstehen, dass man mit jemandem zusammenarbeiten muss, wie uns, der sicherstellt, dass eben das Dokument richtig vernünftig verarbeitet wird.
Das geht über irgendwelche Rauschmuster, Digitalkamera-Fotos, das können irgendwelche Eigenarten von Scannern sein. Das können aber auch selbst wie ein Wasserzeichen in einem Text sein. Das heißt also auch, dass selbst Texte, wenn jetzt von irgendwelchen Dokumenten eine überschaubare Anzahl, vielleicht 10 Stück ausgegeben worden sind, dass auch möglicherweise im Dokument auch bestimmte Muster versteckt sind. Könnt ihr sowas eigentlich auch rausfinden?
Ja, wir haben für verschiedene Organisationen, die solche Methoden verwenden, wissen wir, welche Methoden da verwendet werden und können darauf reagieren.
Also dass zum Beispiel einfach irgendwelche Lehrzeichen irgendwo eingefügt werden, Buchstaben ausgetauscht werden oder sowas.
Was in der Regel hilft, ist, dass man sich zum Beispiel eine zweite Kopie besorgt, die von einer anderen Quelle kommt. Sowas haben wir in der Vergangenheit für manche Dokumente gemacht. Und dann kann man sowas abgleichen. Das ist aber auch was, was, sag ich mal, generell überschätzt wird. Weil der Aufwand, Dokumente einzigartig zu gestalten, ist extrem hoch. Vor allem, wenn man nicht weiß, wie viele diese Dokumente unter Umständen rausgegeben werden müssen. Wenn wir jetzt von einer Regierungsorganisation zum Beispiel sprechen, kann es sein, dass jemand eine Notiz macht zu einem bestimmten Dokument. Dann muss dieses Dokument viel weiter verteilt werden innerhalb der Regierung, als das vielleicht vorher gedacht war. Das muss zu anderen Ressorts gegeben werden, die müssen da von den Kenntnissen gesetzt werden usw. Und das skaliert eben so eine Lösung nicht mehr, wo Dokumente so einzigartig sind, dass man hinterher sagen kann, diese Leerzeile gehört zu ihm hier. Das sind Sachen, die theoretisch natürlich existieren, aber in der Praxis extrem selten vorkommen. Und von daher, wir haben wirklich sehr viel Erfahrung damit entwickelt. Uns ist noch kein bekannter Fehler unterlaufen. Und das ist etwas, wo ich wirklich jeden nur ermutigen kann, einfach mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten. Man kann sich auch sehr schnell das Tor Browser Bundle zum Beispiel organisieren. Damit kann man anonym im Netz sich bewegen, kann sich irgendwo anonym eine E-Mail-Adresse registrieren. Und wenn irgendwelche Fragen sind und man sich wirklich Gedanken macht, wendet man sich einfach so an uns.
Könnt ihr da eigentlich noch einen Dienst empfehlen für anonyme E-Mails?
Es gibt fastmail.fm zum Beispiel funktioniert aus meiner Erfahrung jetzt zum Beispiel ganz gut. Das ist sehr unkompliziert, sich da anzumelden. Ich würde vermeiden, irgendwelche Services zum Beispiel in den USA zu nehmen, weil da eben bekannt ist, wie viele oder dass die NSA eigentlich den gesamten E-Mail-Verkehr screenen. Also kleinere E-Mail-Dienste sind da eigentlich ganz okay. Und wenn man dann schaut, dass man eben seine Verbindung anonymisiert, dann ist das eigentlich schon in Ordnung. Das ist der wichtigere Teil eigentlich.
Aber das ist dann auch schon wieder ein anderes Thema, was von Wikileaks so ein bisschen weit wegführt. Da haben wir auch mal ein Chaos Radio gemacht zum Thema anonymen im Netz surfen, anonymes mail schicken. chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Webseite, da gibt es die Podcasts der alten Sendung. Wir kommen nochmal zu dem Beispiel zurück, was du ganz am Anfang genannt hast, nämlich die Geschichte mit dem angeblichen positiven Aids-Test von Steve Jobs. Dazu hat es Andreas angerufen. Hallo Andreas, guten Abend.
Ich habe eine ganz einfache Frage dazu. Was wäre denn gewesen, wenn dieses Dokument jetzt verifiziert worden wäre? Hättet ihr das dann veröffentlicht? Also wenn ihr gesagt hättet, okay, der ist AIDS krank, hättet ihr das dann veröffentlicht?
Ja, also in dem Fall wäre das Dokument eh noch weitläufig woanders zirkuliert worden, aber es wäre etwas gewesen, das wir so veröffentlicht hätten. Ich muss auch ganz ehrlich für mich persönlich dazu sagen, dass bei gewissen Sachen das so, es ist schon immer eine Gratwanderung und bei manchen Sachen habe ich persönlich auch ein gewisses Bauchweh. Aber wir machen das jetzt mehr als zwei Jahre und wenn eines klar ist, uns allen, die beteiligt sind, dann mittlerweile ist uns allen klar, dass man diese Linie so fahren muss. Ansonsten gibt es keine Möglichkeiten, solches Projekt zu machen. Das ist das Problem. Ich setze alle meine Glaubwürdigkeit bei einer Quelle aufs Spiel, wenn der Eindruck entsteht, dass ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise vorfiltre, was publiziert wird oder nicht. Und es wird nie möglich sein, transparent zu machen, wessen Interessen ich dabei vertrete, ob ich für irgendjemand das Agenda arbeite, ob ich selbst persönliche Interessen darin habe oder wie auch immer.
Aber es geht nicht um Interessen, es geht einfach um das persönliche Leben, dieses Menschen. Da ist das Problem dabei.
Das ist auf einer menschlichen Ebene natürlich sehr verständlich. Andererseits, gerade bei Steve Jobs, bei dem Beispiel, das ist eine amerikanische Persönlichkeit und in Amerika wäre es überhaupt keine Frage, ob die Presse eine solche Sache veröffentlichen würde oder nicht. Das wäre ein ganz klares Ja. Bitte?
Es geht ja nicht um die amerikanische Presse, es geht um dich, ob du es machst.
Aber Daniel hat ja gerade eben gesagt, er persönlich hätte Bauchschmerzen damit, aber es gibt einen, kann ich das Codex nennen von Wikileaks, so kann man das sagen, also eine Grundstruktur, nach der Wikileaks arbeitet und sie sagen, sie werden nichts filtern, sondern alles veröffentlichen.
Es bin ja auch nicht ich persönlich, der das veröffentlicht, nur um das auch dazu zu sagen. Das ist eine etwas kompliziertere Konstruktion.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall schwierig, wenn man das macht.
Natürlich, das würde ich auch gar nicht bestreiten wollen.
Da wird es halt schwierig mit der Wahrheit, ob man da persönliche Dinge veröffentlicht über jemand, der das vielleicht gar nicht haben will.
Dafür sind wir aber wieder beim Punkt öffentliche Personen usw. Dass gerade Informationen zu Steve Jobs und seiner Gesundheitslage es gang und gäbe, dass das von der Presse heiß diskutiert wird. Das ist auch nichts, was groß umstritten ist.
Wobei es natürlich schon auch eine Frage ist. Ich würde mich da auch anschließen, der Kritiker, dass ich sage, es muss eigentlich nicht... Nur weil es die Presse gern diskutiert, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass es auch in Ordnung ist, so etwas zu veröffentlichen.
Das will ich auch gar nicht bestreiten.
Wenn da die Krankenschwester von dem Arzt sozusagen die geheimen Daten euch schickt, dann kann das schon sehr schwierig sein, das zu veröffentlichen.
Das ist auch ganz klar. Ja, das will ich auch hier gar nicht bestreiten. Aber das Beispiel Steve Jobs kommt...
Ich habe gefragt, ob der Grenze, wo man irgendwie aufpassen muss, und das ist so ein Beispiel, da habe ich mich so ein bisschen gewundert, dass man das nicht bemerkt hat sofort, dass da sozusagen eine Grenze sein könnte.
Das haben wir sehr wohl bemerkt. Aber was dieses Realbeispiel Steve Jobs Aids-Test angeht, ist jetzt wichtig, das als Fake zu exponieren. Und wir haben leider, das ist jetzt hochthetisch, aber... Wir haben leider im Moment keine Möglichkeit, oder ich habe kein praktisches Beispiel, wo ich jetzt sagen kann, da haben wir Persönlichkeitsrechte verletzt, wo ich der Meinung bin, das hätten wir nicht tun sollen oder so. Das Beispiel gibt es in der Realität leider noch nicht. Oder das heißt leider, zum Glück nicht. Von daher ist es schwierig, das jetzt zu etablieren irgendwie und darüber zu diskutieren, was wäre wenn.
Weil es ja genau andersrum passiert ist. Ich hab diese Publikation als Fake entlarvt.
Aber es geht darum, die Frage, wo man da aufhört, das war doch das Problem der ganzen Sendung. Also die Grundfrage der Sendung, ab welchem Punkt man das nicht macht. Und da gibt es eben auch Dinge, die man vielleicht nicht sagen sollte. Und da kann man sich schon fragen, wozu sagen, so eine positive Zensur auch okay ist. Ja, das ist doch die Frage.
Ja, aus meiner Erfahrung, was die Arbeit mit dem Projekt betrifft, stellt sich die Frage so nicht. Aber ich verstehe natürlich die Bedenken. Danke für den Kommentar.
Wahrscheinlich wird die Frage euch in Zukunft immer wieder mal treffen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ihr seid seit etwa zwei Jahren jetzt online.
Das ist ja auch der Punkt. Wir haben ein Projekt hier, dass wir zum einen als was sehen, was über einen sehr langen Zeitraum existieren wird. Also wir haben nicht vor, das innerhalb der nächsten Jahre oder Jahrzehnte oder wie auch immer wieder einzustellen, sondern wir planen eigentlich für die Unendlichkeit. Und wir möchten etwas schaffen, was einen Mehrwert für die Gesellschaft in ihrer zukünftigen Entwicklung hat. Gleichzeitig ist es ja aber was, was so noch niemand unternommen hat. Somit betreten wir Pionierland. Und es gibt auch viele Fragen, wenn man Pionierland betritt, die überhaupt nicht vorher geklärt sind, wo wir Erfahrungen machen müssen, um uns selbst auch einzupendeln und Grenzen auszuloten, um zu sehen, was ist möglich, was ist nicht möglich, was sind Fehler und dann aus diesen Fehlern halt auch zu lernen. Aber es ist Teil einer ganz normalen Entwicklung.
Aber bei dem Beispiel Steve Jobs nochmal, also die Frage ist natürlich richtig, auf der einen Seite ist Steve Jobs eine öffentliche Person, der eine Firma vertritt, diese Firma wiederum hat wirtschaftliche Interessen, da hängt eine Menge Geld dran und so weiter und so fort. Und es gibt auch Leute, die diese Firma natürlich droppetieren wollen. Das auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite ist er eine Privatperson, der sein absolutes Recht hat auf die Wahrung seiner persönlichen Intimsphäre und wo man eigentlich sagen muss, es geht keinem was an, wie viele Weisheitszähne der Mann noch im Bund hat. Wir kommen mal dazu, ich glaube Martin hat eine Frage, die etwa in die ähnliche Richtung drückt. Hallo Martin, guten Abend.
Hallo, ja und zwar generell zum Thema High Society und wenn dazu irgendwelche Dokumente auftauchen. Ob das jetzt ist Michael Schumacher, wie viele Punkte hat er in Flensburg oder wer teilt wie sein Vermögen, ist ja schon mal spazierfahrend von der High Society. Also ein Kleinkram, der halt auch an den Nachrichten auftauchen könnte.
Ja, also es gibt keine Beispiele jetzt, wo jemand uns den Flensburger Bericht geschickt hat von irgendwem oder irgendwas in der Art. Aber wir haben natürlich auch schon Dokumente zu prominenten Persönlichkeiten oder zu Leuten, die sich im politischen Umfeld bewegen. Da ist ja zum Beispiel das Beispiel, was wir vorhin hatten mit den jungen Vertretern der CDU. Das ist ja eines der Beispiele, wo aus dem politischen Umfeld transparent wird, was da so gespielt wird. Das hängt wie immer, wie alle anderen Dokumente auch davon ab, ob sich jemand motiviert, was einzusenden. Und wer hat denn überhaupt von irgendeinem prominenten den Flensburger Bericht und hat gleichzeitig die Motivation, unsere Webseite zu besuchen, nimmt das Ding dann auch noch mit nach Hause, hat, wenn er zu Hause ankommt, immer noch die Motivation, die Webseite zu besuchen und das da hochzuladen. Das ist alles eine Frage davon, auch was derjenige davon hat. Die Motivation ist bei dieser ganzen Sache immer eine große Frage.
Und die moralische Sache im Prinzip dahinter, dass es dann auch irgendwie eben halt ein bisschen zu weit gehen könnte oder dass es halt auch ein bisschen an der Serisität von Wikileaks kratzen könnte, wenn da halt eben hochherne Prominente ausspioniert werden, im weiteren Sinne.
Also ich denke, dass das, was an unserer Reputation kratzen könnte, wäre, wenn wir irgendwann ertappt werden, dass wir filtern und bestimmte Sachen bevorzugen, während wir andere eben beiseitekehren. Das ist das, wo ich sehe, dass ich einen Ruf verlieren könnte bei dem, was wir machen. Das andere sind halt Sachen, die müssen sich einpendeln.
Also das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt Berichte von irgendwelchen Stalkern bekommt, dann werdet ihr das auch nachheben.
Ein Bericht von einem Stalker würde voraussetzen, dass der Stalker den selbst verfasst hat. Das ist ein selbst verfasstes Dokument und ist für uns nicht weiter relevant, weil das kein Dokument ist in dem Moment.
Der hat natürlich noch einen Anhang mit dran. Aber so im weiteren Sinne, wenn es jetzt einen Stalker von einem Prominenten gibt, der irgendwie die Post durchwühlt oder so, dann würdet ihr selbstverständlich auch dem nachheben.
Das ist schon wie eine hätte-wäre-wenn-Diskussion.
Sehr konstruiertes Beispiel leider. Das lässt sich nicht so beantworten.
Aber im Prinzip, ihr würdet über euch eure Sachen auch veröffentlichen?
Ja, das hatten wir ja auch schon. Also es gibt dieses Beispiel.
Also auch euch persönlich jetzt?
Ja, wir haben ja diesen Paypal-Account gehabt, der momentan inaktiv ist, aber bald hoffentlich wieder zur Verfügung steht, auf dem wir Spenden entgegennehmen können. Wir bedanken uns dann immer mit einer Mail an die Spender und haben bei einer dieser Mails, die glaube ich an 60 Leute oder so rausging, standen die alle in dem CC-Feld von der Mail drin und nicht im BCC-Feld. Somit konnte jeder, der diese Mail empfangen hat, sehen, wer sonst noch gespendet hatte im selben Zeitrahmen und das hat dann keine Stunde gedauert. Und uns hat jemand diese Mail zugeschickt als Leak und wir mussten dann diesen Leak publizieren, der quasi einen Teil unserer Unterstützung offengelegt hat. Aber das ist genauso konsequent. Das, was wir machen, müssen wir das genauso konsequent behandeln. Da gibt es auch von unserer Seite, auch wenn jetzt jemand heute etwas über mich irgendwie offenlegt, gibt es keine Möglichkeit, dass ich mir überlege, das doch nicht zu publizieren.
Das heißt eigentlich der beste Weg, gegen euch vorzugehen, ist möglichst euch allen hinterher zu spionieren und alles zu veröffentlichen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man damit gegen uns vorgeht, ernsthaft. Das Einzige, was dabei rauskommen könnte, ist, dass jemand beführt, wie viel ich für das Projekt arbeite. Also das würde etabliert werden über meine Verfolgung. Das wäre eher positiv.
Mal noch eine andere Frage. Jetzt wo die Wahlen vor der Tür stehen, wird da irgendwie bemerkt, dass auch mehr Dokumente sozusagen wahlintern extra sich anhäusend geben, um einer anderen Partei vor den Karten zu kippen.
Das gibt's. Also wir haben schon einige Dokumente aus dem Wahlumfeld bekommen in der letzten Zeit. Und wir haben ja auch diese Most Wanted Liste, die haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also wir haben eine Liste zusammengestellt mit Dokumenten, die verschiedenste Menschen auf der Welt gerne sehen möchten. Also sehr viele Organisationen, die gesagt haben, wir wissen von dem und dem Dokument, wir versuchen das seit Jahren zu bekommen und wir hätten das sehr gerne. Diese Liste ist international. Ich glaube, es sind über 30 Länder der Welt vertreten. Und das geht einmal querbeet durch die Art von Dokumenten, die es gibt. Auf dieser Liste stehen auch Dokumente, die jetzt im Umfeld dieser Wahl zum Beispiel relevant wären. Also ob das jetzt irgendwie die Fadenbücher von Frau von der Leyen sind oder die Stasi-Akte von Angela Merkel oder sowas in der Art.
Die Toll-Collects-Verträge sind wahrscheinlich auch immer noch drauf.
Ja, die stehen auch noch mit drauf. 17.000 Seiten. Natürlich ist jeder, der zu uns kommt und uns ein Dokument gibt, in irgendeiner Art und Weise motiviert. Der kann auch motiviert sein, dass er extrem frustriert ist, weil sein Chef ihn schlecht behandelt hat oder so. Aber es heißt nicht, dass diese Motivation schlecht ist. Sondern das heißt, dass ein Mensch durch irgendetwas getriggert wurde, um etwas transparent zu machen für das Wohl der Gesellschaft in dem Moment. Und das ist das, was unterstützt werden muss eben.
Martin, Frage beantwortet, uns läuft jetzt langsam die Zeit weg.
Ja danke auch, tschüss.
Wir schaffen noch ganz schnell Carsten. Hallo Carsten, guten Abend.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Los, fix.
Okay, also ich habe eine ganz allgemeine Frage. Und zwar habt ihr am Anfang gesagt, dass ihr halt die Dokumente nicht löschen könnt.
Ja.
Und was ist denn jetzt, wenn ihr was reingestellt habt und irgendwann merkt, dass es vielleicht doch falsch ist oder manipuliert ist oder so, aber später halt, nachdem ihr es reingestellt habt, könnt ihr dann noch irgendwas machen?
Wir publizieren ja nicht ein Dokument, ohne dass das Dokument einen Kontext bekommt. Also jedes Dokument hat diesen sogenannten Lick Descriptor. Und auf dem Lick Descriptor steht eine Zusammenfassung des Dokuments. Da steht eine Beschreibung, die die Quelle des Dokuments uns unter Umständen gegeben hat und weitere Kontextinformationen. Unter anderem würde da stehen, ob das Dokument echt ist oder eine Fälschung ist. Im schlimmsten Fall würden wir feststellen, wir haben eine Fälschung als echt markiert und müssen diese Beschreibung dann ändern und sicherstellen, dass die Änderung dieser Beschreibung kommuniziert wird zu allen Leuten, die es mitbekommen haben. Das wäre was, wo wir uns dann natürlich in dem Moment einen Fehler eingestehen müssten. Andererseits, wenn es eine Fälschung ist, genau wie bei dem Steve Jobs Dokument, jede Fälschung oder jeder Versuch an einer Fälschung hat er natürlich auch seine eigene Geschichte. Und dann in dem Moment wird interessant, warum gibt es diese Fälschung, was war die Motivation dahinter, das zu fälschen, was hat jemand versucht. Und damit kommt man dann in einen ganz anderen Themenbereich.
Ein kleiner Exkurs in die Welt von Wikileaks.de. Carsten, danke dir für den Anruf. Fritz.de klicken, da gibt es den Podcast der Sendung, die gibt es genauso unter chaosradio.ccc.de und ansonsten wikileaks.org ist die Adresse. Daniel Schmidt war bei uns von Wikileaks. Frank vom ccc hat noch zwei Ansagen zu machen, die wir noch schaffen. Guckst du mich an? Ansagen, Ansagen, Ansagen.
Kongress. Kongress hatten wir. Machen wir gerne nochmal. Klar. Also, Kongress zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr in Berlin. Im Kongresszentrum am Alex, der jährliche Kongress des Chaos Computer Clubs. Mit ganz vielen Vorträgen, Workshops, Feiern, Abhängen, Leute treffen und Spaß haben.
Und am 12. September Demo nicht vergessen.
Die Freiheits-Stadt-Angst-Demo in Berlin. 15 Uhr geht es los. Könnt ihr im Netz auch alles nachlesen. Es wäre extrem wichtig, dass alle kommen und jeder noch 10 Leute mitbringt. Mindestens.
Euch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war mein letztes Chaos-Radio, weil ab demnächst wird der Kollege Markus Richter das übernehmen, weil ich einfach keine Zeit mehr habe, das zu machen. Hat extrem viel Spaß gemacht. Ich höre auf jeden Fall weiterhin rein. Gleich geht es weiter mit dem Kollegen Smith & Smart, die hier gigantische Beats bauen. Und da wir gerade beim Leaken sind, Kollege Zane Low von BBC hat gestern Nacht die neue Massive Attack gespielt. Hier ist sie.